you would play drinking games too we
would we are not on set but we would we
played this brilliant game called
tequila slaps does anyone know tequila
slaps no it didn't x-men thing yeah you
want to play yeah I said you wanted to
do something with me I don't know what
it is but I'll do this but I will do it
if you if you walk me through it okay so
basically two people stand opposite one
another one person takes a shot and
before they have time to swallow it the
other person slap somewhere on the face
did you bring your bike for the tip all
that to call that a game it seems you
know I didn't wanna ski and I'll just
pull one for myself because I'm getting
on the fly tonight okay yeah thank you
so Andy just gets to have a drink
probably about getting sick so wait so
okay this is the game yeah yeah is that
I take this I already know who the
winner is the winner is you because you
get to what do we stand please stand
okay you're nice and tall I like that
thank you okay so you take the shot okay
and how much time do I get just go
that was that was a pink plastic
[Applause]
Wow while she's looking that way I mean
man you don't screw around
okay I don't know you don't screw around
all right a purple hand mark on my face
from laying that game came on your show
the next day is have you hit someone
that hard playing this game before
hada we go really really hard with each
other now our men slapping you in the
humor men slamming I mean you give them
permission yes wow that's quite a
workplace
are you gonna drink that whole time
making wait until the pain goes away
don't be sorry I love that that was
fantastic I can dine out on that for
years
I got it commit to the bit yeah yeah the
most exciting thing that's happened to
me a long time all right we have a clip
here from Dark Phoenix I don't even know
that this needs to be set up I think
government types I've come looking for
you yeah and you're seeking shelter with
some of the other x-men is that right
absolutely I could pretty well for a guy
who's been beaten up and half drunk
let's say look at this clip from Dark
Phoenix this land was given to us by the
US government we have no intention of
taking it back we're not here for you
looking for one of the x-men Jean Grey
look I know you are I don't want to
fight not you don't
stop that I said stop that right now
it's not me it's me gee
Haggar Phoenix is in theaters on Friday
ladies and gentlemen it doesn't get
better than this sophie Turner